two former students at the University of
Illinois at urbana-champaign are
accusing a former professor of sexual
physical and emotional abuse they filed
a complaint in federal court and claimed
the university protected Gary Shue
despite numerous allegations and
complaints against him Meg Oliver sat
down with one of the women Venus Sun who
told us professor Xu abused her for
around two years using the fact she was
an international student against her son
spoke only with CBS this morning he
tried to kill me he tried to kill you
tried to kill me
Venus Sun says this photo was taken
after one of her many beatings at the
hands a former University of Illinois
professor Gary Shu in 2013 when she was
19
the married 45 year-old became her
professor and she says they started a
relationship that quickly became abusive
I didn't seriously date anyone before
him I didn't know what was love how many
times did he rape you that's too much I
don't remember too traumatizing but I'll
say none of the sex especially after the
fight was consensual the fights were
frequent she says and in one incident
she thought she would die he was after
me and then he went to the parking lot
and started his car driving after me
trying to crash me in the street he was
trying to run you down correct I was so
scared and I was actually surprised that
someone tried to just kill me in public
how many times did you report professor
shoe to the University so I believe
eventually three times I felt like they
wanted to sweep it under the rock that's
for sure according to the complaint
after that incident Shu was put on a
paid sabbatical by the University for
two school years he was paid his full
salary of more than $85,000 in 2018 he
was allegedly allowed to resign and
given a $10,000 bonus he then went on to
teach at other universities and all of
our use is sons attorney she was so
vulnerable he had so much power over her
university didn't seem to
pick up on that inquire into that nobody
followed up according to a recent
investigation by ProPublica and NPR
Illinois since last year allegations of
harassment and sexual misconduct have
surfaced against three professors and an
administrator from the school and in
each instance the public wasn't told by
the university until news organizations
or others brought the allegations to
light Sun who says she has been
diagnosed with PTSD is trying to move
forward are you amazed that you're still
alive sometimes yes I'm gonna lift this
the whole life in a statement a
spokesperson for the university said
it's aware of the complaint and is
reviewing it adding it investigates and
takes appropriate action whenever
conduct is reported that may jeopardize
or impact the safety or security of our
students or others phone numbers for
Gary Shue have been disconnected and we
have not been able to reach him I'd be
very curious to see what Professor shoe
has to say about all of this especially
when you see the the pictures of Venus
sons black eye and they're also planning
to file a lawsuit against the University
of Illinois this Friday however we have
learned that the legal team for the
university reached out to them and they
are in the beginning talks to try to
reach an agreement before they file suit
is he still working do we know we don't
know that right now you say he's off
campus with this but that's not what we
were surrounding him we'll be following
it make thank you very much